Hello!
Hi, Candace. Hello.
Hi, Candice! Happy Friday!
How are you?
Yeah.
Happy Friday!
Are you?
I am, I'll be better once I can get this one MFA to work properly.
Yeah.
Pretty good.
Not me.
Not sure with Andrea.
It.
Yeah, I was out of tech for like the past few days, so not good. It's fine.
It's been going around.
Yeah, it is. I think it's the weather for some reason, maybe.
Mhm.
He.
Good, yeah, I'm good.
All right, so shall we start?
Absolutely, ready when you guys are.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm just going to share my screen.
All right, so this is a feedback session again for Jericho. So that's going to be for week 2 to 4, just to wrap it up for this month. So.
Agenda, again, check-ins, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, way forward, and recap. So before we start, Candice, I just want to ask, is there any updates or anything that we need to know for us to cascade it to the team here?
No, I think all is well. You know, he's still learning, but he's still also being proactive and isn't afraid to kind of dive in. He communicates well. I will say that we have, we've implemented kind of begin of week and end of week.
team meetings with the owner, sales, like everyone, kind of like almost like a town hall, but it's very, it's just kind of specific with us on this side. And then we do some others to kind of start the weekend and then end the week. He's been a little quiet in those meetings, but that always, it just takes time and he's still learning. And
Mmh.
the systems and, you know, training. So I don't expect a whole lot from him kind of in those. But I would say all in all, he's handling himself well and handling his tickets well.
That's great. I think he's a shy type guy. So I think he's gonna he's gonna use to how things work here in the organization. So hopefully after a few months, you're gonna participate or at least talk or respond to the things that you guys are.
Talking about so.
Yeah, I will say if he's asked, you know, a direct question, if there's something that I know he was specifically working on, he responds clearly and he articulates himself very well. It's kind of just that follow up. Does anyone have anything else, anything we may have missed or something you're working on or you've noticed?
that he hasn't really kind of stepped up just yet as far as those kind of end of meeting questions. But yeah, if he's if he's directly asked about something he's been involved in, he's he articulates well. He's very he's communicative.
Mm.
Okay.
That's nice. All right, thanks so much for that. So let's move on. So highlights, observation first. Angela has noted that Jericho onboarding has freed her capacity to take on more complex tickets, reflecting early integration success, which is great. It regards the performance within his first week.
Mhm.
Jerome has proactively taken ownership of alerts, backups, and patching responsibilities previously handled by Angela, demonstrating strong initiative and a smooth transition. So I think we have some capacities for Angela that you can like.
No.
assign much more complex tickets or because I've talked to her earlier and she's doing off-boarding tickets. Correct me if I'm wrong. Okay. All right.
Aman.
She has been, yes. Yes. And now starting, we've ordered the equipment as of today, so probably mid next week. And then most of the following week, she will be onboarding, which I think will be a little bit more of a deeper dive in opposed to just passing off information. She's going to
Mm.
have more of a hands-on, so she's going to be onboarding in the next, I'd say, week, week and a half, a new client. So that's.
See how that plays out. It's gonna be interesting. Let her, let her, let her get her hands dirty.
Yeah, so for the most, yeah, okay, and in regards to monitoring, in addition to the existing auto task gauge that I created for Jericho, I've also added Jericho to the real-time spreadsheet tracker that I've that I have here, so that...
Yeah.
for me to ensure full visibility on his tickets volume and utilization going forward. But I just want to inform you as well, Candace, that I'm trying to gauge their utilization, but unfortunately earlier when I tried to check their auto task, the non-billables are not recorded as well in auto task. So.
Yeah, they're not.
Yeah, let's talk about it on the next slide. So let's move on.
Yeah, that's been an ongoing kind of thing for us. We are actively, I had an additional consulting call yesterday, actively moving into the ConnectWise PSA. So the goal is it's always going to be, you know, the first part of the next month.
Mhm.
About.
Once we are in the PSA, those little areas, I know we're going to be able to dabble deeper into. So that's been kind of an ongoing problem on this side of auto task. But moving forward, as soon as we're actively in the PSA, and I'm hoping that happens as of July 1st, you should have a better view.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure. Yes. Plus, based on my experience, Connectwise is much user-friendly and it's much easier for them to navigate. So
All right, so performance reviews, ticket closure trend and analysis. So overview, this is for week two, three, and four for May. So basically across the three reporting periods, May 11 to 29, Jerome processed at least 49 total tickets and successfully closed 19.
tickets resulting in an overall average resolution rate of 48%. Lowest performance is made 25 to 29, but he just bugged me earlier, at least less than a minute, and he added something on week 25 and 29. So this is not accurate, the 25 and 29, because he added at least.
14 tickets there, so a total of 739, if I'm not mistaken. But yeah, he's doing great in terms of the numbers, tickets work on and also ticket closures. But yeah, I'm looking forward for him to be confident enough to work on some complicated things.
Mm.
Tickets with the help of Angela and other colleagues that you guys have, so...
Question, Marky. Yeah, if we can go back to that. Yep. So it's a bit low for the ticket close. Do we know why the resolution rate has dipped?
Yep.
Yes, because of the correction. Earlier, it's supposed to be like this, but the total tickets that he updated just less than a minute earlier before we start the meeting is, let me check how many.
Well, there he is in his personal life.
Sorry.
Yeah.
I'll just get a double check just to be sure. Utilization, yeah, it's 77% for week 4.
Okay.
Total tickets, yeah, 77%. Yes, resolution rate for week 4. Because earlier we only have three tickets there that he closed, but he modified the tracker and now it's running 17. So the total percentage of resolution rate is already 27%.
77% is the resolution.
Okay, gotcha. So probably you needed to also advise him and make sure that he knows to update a tracker real time, so that you won't have any problems with getting the accurate data for him. Because I feel like he's doing a lot of things, but since the only source of truth that we have right now is the utilization tracker,
Yep.
then we won't be able to give justice to the things that he do on a daily basis.
Right, I agree. Okay.
And I will say to add to that as well, there is a little bit on this side of that as well, not necessarily updating tickets in real time. Not that he's not doing it. He is updating tickets. And when he does, his notes are very clear, very concise. Anyone could pick it up and take over.
Mhm.
But I have had to ask a couple of times for an update that he had. He just hadn't quite added the note to the ticket just yet. So I'll continue on my side as well to kind of pick at that. So, you know, but that's, I think he may just be doing that, just getting it all done and then updating.
Ticket AG.
Mhm.
Yeah.
True.
opposed to updating in real time.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Yeah, so more on ticket management, basically.
Okay, I'll take note of that. Once I have a catch up with him, I'm going to address those concerns. Thank you. So let's move on to Way Forward. So again, Angela stays available to support Jericho's technical growth on an as needed basis, ensuring continuity,
without affecting her capacity gains. For the meantime, for us to capture the utilization, agree or disagree, that's okay, Candace. But I suggest for the meantime, both Angela and Jericho will create a ticket, like for monitoring or admin tasks, so that they can.
you know, capture the time, how long did they spend on specific ticket on the alert, especially in Altaro, because they mentioned that if they see some alerts on Altaro, they don't create ticket. They're just going to jump into that alert straight up and try to fix it without.
them, you know, tracking their time.
Yeah, no, that's perfectly, that's perfectly fine. And if you want to, and I can do this on my end as well, when they're creating that ticket, because I'm actively trying to move everyone into everything's a ticket. And even myself, I'll get caught up in a conversation and just go do something and not think to create a ticket for it. So
So...
Uh-huh.
It's something we're all actively working to just be better for, you know, best practices. But for a company name on that ticket, if they'll just select RCTA, it's not going to attach to any individual company. So when it comes into the end of month billing, it's not going to affect anything.
Mhm.
it would just show their time. So that's a really good ticket and a good company to associate it with so they can subtract.
Okay.
Okay, all right. I'll take note of that. Thank you. So we're going to start doing this by Monday, just for us to, you know, try it and let's see what's going to be the result for their utilization. So that's for the meantime. And in regards to a long-term solution,
No.
for accurately capturing utilization, we recommend, like you mentioned, you're going to be migrating to ConnectWise. So best suggestion is to migrate alerts from AutoTask or from Altaro going to ConnectWise. It will going to create a specific ticket for a specific alert so that
they'll not gonna create a ticket for like monitoring or admin tasks that the guys are doing. This approach will provide more precise and reliable data for tracking individual staff utilization.
Absolutely.
Okay, alright, next, uh, yeah.
Yeah, so usually...
Yeah, so usually Candace, I think it's an API. We can grab the API from Altaro and then just integrate that to ConnectWise, just so it's automatically closed also. So what we did in the past, or what I've done in the past, is I have a monitoring tool. I've been using Avic in the past. So every time that there was an alert from Avic,
One.
Mhm.
from that monitoring tool, it will create a ticket. And then in order for you to actually clear out that ticket, it sets to autocomplete once that alert from the tool itself has been cleared out. So you don't have to manually close this alert ticket. It would automatically clear it out once.
you were able to clear out also in the monitoring tool, meaning they don't have to manually close tickets. They just put their time entry. Once it's cleared out to the monitoring tool, it should be completed also.
Perfect. Absolutely. I'm really looking forward to us being fully integrated into the PSA. It's just taken me so long to get everything built up. It's a lot to manually build and not to make it messy and make it very clean and is exactly what we need to be. It's a lot of work.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
A long time.
True.
Yeah.
True structure.
Um, I'm excited to...
Definitely. And this is not just the, yeah, and this is not, ConnectWise is not just about the partner also, it's about the billing, the invoices, SOWs.
That's where we've had the biggest, that has been my biggest struggle currently is because Ryan Creek has been customized for its entirety.
Yeah.
Mhm.
My product catalog, it's not clear, right? So one product will cost several different prices for several different companies, right? So it's like making sure all of those little fine details are exactly right and the agreements are set up properly. So it's
Oh, no.
Yeah.
PH.
Yes.
Yeah.
Exactly. True.
It's been a lot of back, a lot of re-watching the same webinar 15 times to pause it just right to make sure I'm getting it, getting it just right. But it's, I think I'll know everything. I'll probably be an expert by the time I'm done with it, but it's, that's the goal at least.
Yeah.
He.
Exactly. Exactly. Even with the time entries, even with this patch portal, you have to set those up for the guys also so they can actually use them. I hear you. It's a lot of struggle, but it has a payoff. Payoff afterwards.
Mm.
It is.
It does, it doesn't. I'm so looking forward to it. So looking forward to it.
****.
Perfect. Gotcha. But for the meantime, just like what Marky mentioned earlier today, we wanted to make sure that you also know what these guys are doing. Even though you're miles away, you probably know what they're doing, but you got to make sure that, you know, when you present it to the executives also within or internally, then you can show them numbers. I think that's the easiest way.
Okay.
way for them to understand what these guys are doing. So we're going to do that.
And I really, really appreciate that.
You're welcome. We're going to do that for you. And I think it's a great practice also, because once you move to ConnectWise Manage, everything will be on the ticket. So.
Really appreciate that.
Yes, yes, yes. It should all, yeah, it should be. I'm gonna have to send you a couple of tickets and you let me know what areas don't quite look right. But it should, it should all be there.
Mm.
****. All right, go.
Yeah.
Definitely.
Yeah, gotcha. Thanks, Candace. Go ahead, Marky.
Okay, so last one is, it's an ITBD holiday on June 12th, which is Independence Day. So Candice, do you need manpower during that day? It's A Friday, next Friday.
Let me just look at the calendar to see what is going on. Make sure I don't have anything.
That is pressing, pressing.
Um...
That should...
That should be okay.
The 12th, yeah, we have our, yeah, um, well...
Okay.
You sure?
Would I hate to take away holidays? You just know that I hate to take away holidays, but if maybe we can do a split schedule.
Yeah.
I.
Mm.
Maybe do just a couple of hours, just half day of maybe monitoring, but the.
Sure, we can do that.
Yeah, first half, second half.
First half.
Okay, do you want both of them?
Um...
For StaAna.
Let me get back to you. I have a meeting with ownership later today. I hate to take away a holiday. I really, truly do hate to take away a holiday. It would bother me literally all week to do that. So let me have a meeting with ownership later this afternoon and I'll bring that to him and discuss it and
Okay.
All right.
PH.
Okay.
It's Harish.
And I'll let you know by end of day how next Friday will look.
Okay.
Kour.
All right, thank you.
Alright.
Okay, so move on. Let's move on to Build It Live 2026. So Candace, is someone going to attend this?
Unfortunately, we are not able to attend this year. My goal is to attend next year, but each week you just keep rubbing this one in my face like I want to be there so bad and I can't this year. But my goal is to absolutely be a part of it next year. Would love that.
Ohh.
Haha.
****.
Yeah.
The.
Okay.
Gotcha. Just please keep in mind, Candice, that we have BOGO promo. If you wanted that code, let me know.
My schedule wouldn't allow it. I've got, I've got my sister's getting married and you know, it's just, yeah, between the kids and just life changes for people closest to me. I can only, I've got one in November that I'm able to get away
Haha.
Yeah.
Oh wow, congratulations.
Kip.
Gaur.
from but literally my kids are every other day. When are you leaving us again? You are not being abandoned. I'm just going to be gone like 4 days. You can drive a car like you are old enough to be sustained for a couple of days while I'm not here. So yeah.
He.
Yeah.
That's sweet.
Unfortunately, I'm not able to do a whole lot of the fun stuff this year because I got to do the other kind of fun stuff.
Okay.
How about Tim?
How about Tim? Does he wanna?
Tim is no longer with Ryan Creek.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Yeah, no, he decided that for his just career goals and where his life path was taking him, that he went back to the Department of Defense. Because locally here in Alabama, in Huntsville where he is, that's where NASA is.
Mhm.
Okay.
So the space program, all the things. And that's kind of his background. And the previous ownership of Ryan Creek, they were very friendly. I worked in the same building and kind of he needed a break from that world of classification, right? You know, like the Department of Defense and
Mhm.
Wow, fancy.
Mm.
Yeah.
So he was with Brian Creek for several years and decided to...
to go back into that. So he's still very much a part of the team. He assists us often, still. We all still have several questions that would randomly pop up. I know him and Angela still communicate if she kind of gets stuck on something. But yeah, he is no longer with us on a day-to-day. He is back.
Kip.
I'm happy for him.
Yeah.
Mhm.
The.
Back with the government.
Aww.
Got to. I'm happy for him.
Me too. I'm very happy for him. But we do a check-in every once in a while.
It, yeah, it's...
It's a.
Yeah.
the ownership of Ryan Creek. They're in a lot of the same local, like Rotary clubs and things like that. So they still go on mission trips together. So he's still very much a part of the family and the culture. He just, we don't get him on a day to day anymore.
Mhm.
That says a lot, you know.
Wow.
Yeah, but there's a lot about him and how his relationship is with you guys, right? Is there any, is there anybody that replaced him currently?
Oh, absolutely.
Not currently. I know that ownership and like sales, the VP of Sales, they are, they're working in their first year of Evolve. So that's kind of eaten up a lot of that, trying to find that balance, right, of the quarterly reviews and they being away and
Okay.
Mm.
Mhm.
the call, so they're working that. So I think collectively across the board, we are all pretty stationary outside of Evolve, and then we'll go to the Big Evolve conference in November. That's the one I think at this point in our company growth, in our personal growth, we don't have a whole lot of bandwidth to add too much more.
Gotcha.
Mmh.
Gotcha. Speaking of QBR, Candace, I feel like we haven't really known, I feel, I know that we haven't really had a QBR since we started in December, I think. Yeah, so we should have like our first QBR already, but since we have...
Yep.
Not because there are a lot of things happening on your end, and we just recently add Jericho. So, what we're gonna do is to create that QBR or two QBRs in one, if you want. What we what we can do is the first quarter, second quarter, wrap into one presentation, so that we can also add a bit of...
Yeah.
Okay, yeah.
a data from Jericho's side of the fence, even though he doesn't have much yet, but at least he can see it from here. Okay.
Absolutely. And I would love to have ownership on that call as well for them to, because I always take back the information from the calls that we have each week and kind of give them all the information and the updates and our plan of actions and things like that. So, but I think it would be good for them to be at least a part of that conversation.
Yes.
Sure.
If...
Mhm.
Yeah.
speak of July. But yeah, just let me know when is the date that you guys are all free and then we'll schedule appropriately. Okay.
Absolutely. And so I'll talk like I'll talk with them a little later this afternoon and I'll try and lock in that date and I'll so I can inform you about the 12th and that date at the same time would be is definitely my goal for the day.
Sure.
Okay.
Gotcha. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
All right, so Team GPS, so I'm not sure if Andy already explained this to you, but if you're interested, please let us know. We'll be happy to walk you through in regards to Team GPS. So with that being said, any questions, feedbacks, anything in particular that you want to raise, Candace?
What?
I don't think so. We always tend to kind of discuss most of just how every day is going throughout the calls. I think both Angela and Jerome are doing great.
I really have no complaints, truly. They're both phenomenal. Even with the little things of, you know, maybe having to ask for an update on a ticket that he, Jerome, has worked and those are little minor things that can easily be adjusted.
Okay.
No, I think they're doing an amazing job. They allow me a peace of mind to do the things like a product catalog for the PSA. And I appreciate that with them.
So no, there's no true areas of concern. Just will continue to build and grow and learn. And I look forward to the working the onboarding with Angela, us both kind of working that. And I'm glad that she feels comfortable to kind of that she has Jerome as backup.
to her and will clear her mind in a way where she can, will do her absolute best work on the onboarding. Without that, you know, that nagging, there's something waiting in the background. I'm really glad that we now have that in place for her where she can get some relief from that.
Mmh.
Das.
Yeah.
Yes.
PH.
Yeah, at least she can focus now.
Yes, yes, I was.
Speaking of, Candace, I know that they have a pending onboarding plan with you. So sorry I was out for like 2 days, but I'll just share it with you. This is the thing or the document that I had in the past. I had to look it up from the chest.
Hello.
That's okay. Now you're okay.
but this is it. This is the client onboarding I have. It includes prerequisite, the discovery, the config, and the go live. So I'll send this to you, but yeah, no problem. But these are just the contents of that. Pre onboarding, prerequisite, even the post go live. It's all here.
Appreciate that. Absolutely.
So the preparation, who are the time teams, kickoff, network backup, Office 365, and end user support. I think those are the four basic things that we offer as an MSP. So that's what I used in the past also. Network assessment, end user environment assessment, network setup, backup. There's just a lot.
Mmh.
And this also would include the go live before we actually hand it over from project, right, to the team itself. And it also included the handoff to service delivery, because I feel like this is very, very important. But people don't usually do. And then post go live also.
Right.
Eddie has.
The.
We got to make sure that just like what we do with you guys, you check with your end of the client if they're actually happy with the current service. So this is going to be it. I'll share it with you. Let me know if it helps and let me know if you need anything else. OK.
I appreciate that very much.
You're welcome. All right. Anything else aside from those?
I think I'm okay.
All right. Perfect. Parky.
Nothing else. Happy Friday and happy weekend.
Happy Friday! You guys as well. We'll talk soon.
Happy Friday. You too, bye.
Hi.